in health news new research on the
psychological impact of the coronavirus
english scientists found people
diagnosed with covid19 are at a greater
risk of developing a range of
psychological and neurological
conditions
now one man says he wasn't too concerned
when he was diagnosed and eventually
recovered but
things changed very quickly it instantly
like a light switch
i felt this intense paranoia hit me i
couldn't
escape it it kept every single person
that i saw would trigger
this this intense fear and and how bad
did it get
as i was hearing voices outside the
window you know i thought i heard people
in the bushes
doctors were able to link that man's
condition to coronavirus and found out
that he's not alone
oxford researchers say one in three
covid patients in the u.s developed
brain or psychiatric disorders within
six
months of being infected some disorders
were common like anxiety or depression
however some patients developed
psychosis and dementia
they hope future studies will reveal
more about how covet interacts with the
brain